[Music]
[Music]
when it comes to bringing back some
competition to the basketball video game
genre with NBA Live 18 ea took
inspiration from games and progression
systems not normally associated with the
sport this outside influence which is
represented in its career mode called
the one surprisingly manages to
overshadow EA Sports as standard issue
modes like Ultimate Team and franchise
and with the long overdue inclusion of
the WNBA
NBA Live returns to the court from a
one-year hiatus with a loaded game even
if it's not a complete package at the
levels of EAS more stable sports
franchises
[Music]
the one follows ea sports his positive
trend a featuring story-driven single
player career modes although its premise
of a derailed athlete making a comeback
echoes this year's Madden campaign don't
expect a heartfelt narrative and
telltale inspired designs the one is
less about physical recuperation and
more about the rebuilding of one's
personal brand mostly by responding to
trash talk and court challenges it
underscores how well professional
basketball culture has intertwined
itself with social media more so than
other sports and may you live 18 is the
product of the times in more ways than
one
while there is a specific path to
greatness the one is loaded with
optional opportunities to build your
cred and improve your skills beyond the
NBA season this mode leverages popular
elements from MMORPGs and first-person
shooters there are even customizable
skill loadouts which further gamma Phi's
the experience at the expense of
authenticity and a riveting aspect of
the one is how your persistently
evaluated with each ball touch whether
you're penalized for giving your
assigned man an open look or credited
for a ferocious block even a missed
layup turns out to be a positive if you
showed effort by making an assertive
drive to the hoop this grading system
motivates the player to make every
possession count
play of the game
[Applause]
it's a journey enhanced by the fiction
building connective tissue in between
games smartphone chats with best friends
or your agent and even impromptu
interviews with reporters offer a
simplified version of the interconnected
life of the 21st century basketball
player adding to this moderately
immersive fiction is the tiresome
exuberance of ESPN first takes Steven
Naismith and is more tolerable co-host
Max Kellerman who both comment on your
career milestones in unskipable
cinematics the more insightful
intermissions are the videos that remind
players of American basketball culture
that exists beyond the NBA like
introductory videos on Rucker Park in
New York and the drew league in Los
Angeles this is New York City the mecca
of basketball the original ruggedly
began here in 1947 nine years later the
tournament found a permanent home uptown
at PS 156 playground those early record
days showcased talents like Lew Alcindor
will distill an Earl the Pearl yet out
of all the ways EA Sports pays respect
to basketball beyond Men's Pro hoops the
inclusion of WNBA players and team
stands out while it was disappointing
that women ballers don't get
opportunities in the other modes or even
online it was satisfying to play as the
LA Sparks as Candace Parker and Sue Bird
of the Seattle Storm to some surprise
these new modes become the main draws of
NBA Live 18 overshadowing the shallow
franchise mode and unremarkable ultimate
team both of which are serviceable but
lacked engrossing richness of what you
find in other EA Sports series while you
assume the role of a GM and franchise
you like the engaging power to negotiate
complex contracts customized players or
scout prospects before the draft
ultimate team is similarly simplistic as
the mode where you can experiment with
dream teams online or against the CPU
but giving you little reason to come
back after you've played a few dozen
games whatever your mode of choice keep
your highlight reel
spectators low while the faces of NBA
starters are impressive and do their
real-life counterparts justice the
myriad animations don't compare to the
wide range of recognizable moves you'll
find an NBA 2k 18 still these visual
shortcomings don't get in the way of the
solid controls which work well whether
you're a team player or a ball hog
[Applause]
with undergoing that's great body
control right there finishes the shot
and now goes to the free-throw line
[Applause]
NBA Live 18 is a welcome return for EA's
basketball series but doesn't recapture
the series's greatness from over 15
years ago
by contrast the strengths of the one
underscore the uninspired designs of
franchise and Ultimate Team these
mainstays are fine and functional but
feel dated when held up against their
deeper counterparts in madden and NHL
that's not to say this game is short on
replayability between the WNBA matches
and the position variety of the 1 NBA
LIVE succeeds albeit barely as a viable
alternative to NBA 2k 18
[Music]